hi youtuber my name is Philip Jennings
on the general secretary of unique
global Union I'm here at Davos this year
with the trade union delegation to the
workers issues at the forfeit the agenda
very often the problems of working
people and the coven's they have in
their daily working lives is often
forgotten here in the discussions of
what we do is to try and bring an
alternative voice to the discussions
which are taking place the world of
globalization is not working for working
people one in two people at work are now
in vulnerable employment the share of
wages in the wealth produced is as low
now since records were kept since the
Second World War that is the same the
economic pie is actually growing but the
share of wages and earnings of workers
is actually named declined we are faced
with catastrophic inequality in his
global economy of ours if you look at
the roots of the subprime crisis why did
it happen it happened because people at
the lower end of the income scale the
scale could not be their debts could not
meet their repayments and that has
spiraled into a global financial
contagion in seeking solutions I ask all
the participants here at Davos the
business people and governments to think
of the people in the center of the storm
and I think in this process we should
also recognize the role of unions play
and the rights of trade unions to
organize this year we have the 60th
anniversary of the ILO convention on the
freedom of association never has there
been so much pressure on working people
turn away from trade unions we see
abuses of trade union rights all over
the world and if we're going to make a
dent in inequality if we're going to
improve working conditions of people
then we need those rights to organize
and we read we need to negotiate working
conditions you defeat inequality by a
fair bargain and the fair bargain has to
be done with strong social partners and
a strong trade union movement and that's
why we are here to
this message we are here talking to
business leaders and to two governments
about dealing with these people issues I
have one hope is that in our work is
that the 250 million children at work
should be able to go to school it is a
global scandal that we are still faced
with 250 million people under the age of
four forty or at work it's also a
scandal to us that many governments are
trying to attract the investment around
the world by eliminating trade union
item export processing zones around 15
million even export processing zone
where there's no right to organize so
let's celebrate the 60th anniversary of
the right to organize let's help rebuild
the national trade union movement like
strengthen the global trade union
movement we are ready to innovate we're
ready to collaborate but not just to
collaborate but to negotiate for a fair
review for working people on this planet
it can be done it takes political will
and these organizations out there like
uni fighting for you to improve to
improve your working conditions and your
standards of living thank you YouTube
has the block